[Music]
the term elastic Cloud growing or
shrinking Cloud resources in a pinch has
become a bit of a buzzword but when then
automatically it can be really powerful
and you can do so automatically on
Google Cloud VMware engine or gcve to
expand or Shrink the cluster in your
private Cloud environment
in this video you will learn about the
auto scaling policies in gcve and how to
configure it to manage Dynamic workloads
much more efficiently
gcp offers different types of Auto scale
policies like storage capacity CPU
performance memory performance and CPU
and memory performance optimization
policies you can choose to apply an
appropriate policy based on your needs
let's start by looking at each of these
policies in more detail
storage capacity optimization policy
adds a node when storage consumption
goes above 80 percent and removes a node
when storage consumption goes below 40
percent
CPU performance optimization policy adds
a node when CPU utilization goes above
70 percent or storage consumption goes
above 80 percent and removes a node when
CPU utilization goes below 45 percent
and storage consumption goes below 40
percent
memory performance optimization policy
adds a note when memory utilization goes
above 80 percent or storage consumption
goes above 80 percent and removes a node
when memory utilization goes below 45
percent and storage consumption goes
below 40 percent
CPU and memory performance optimization
policy adds a node when CPU utilization
goes above 70 percent on memory
utilization goes above 80 percent or
storage consumption goes above 80
percent and removes the node when CPU
utilization goes below 45 percent and
memory utilization goes below 45 percent
and storage consumption goes below 40
percent be aware there are some
scenarios or limitations under which
Auto scaling doesn't work in GCV private
Cloud environments firstly if the GCV
nodes have reached the maximum number of
nodes for the cluster or maximum quota
for the region then Auto scaling cannot
add any more nodes next if the GCB nodes
have reached their minimum limit
configured for the cluster then Auto
scaling will not remove any nodes
lastly Auto scale policies are not
available on clusters containing a
single node
to configure or modify Auto scale policy
in your private Cloud environment you
must have the identity and access
management or IAM role VMware engine
service admin this role has admin access
to VMware engine resources and the
required permissions to perform these
tasks
now let's dive into a demo and configure
storage capacity optimization policy on
a cluster
in the Google Cloud console go to the
VMware engine page from the left pane
click on resources followed by the
private Cloud name where you want to
configure Auto scale
click on the Clusters tab to list the
Clusters within that private Cloud click
on the pencil icon to edit the auto
scale policy configuration of the
specific cluster select the auto scale
policy drop down menu
choose an appropriate Auto scale policy
based on your requirements in this
example we will select storage capacity
optimization policy
in the add nodes drop down you can
specify the number of nodes to be added
by Auto scale remember only one node can
be removed at a time so remove nodes is
grayed out
you can use the slider to set the cool
off period default value is 30 minutes
this means VMware engine will trigger
the auto scale action to add or remove
nodes if the metrics breached the
threshold for the time duration
specified in the cool off period
in the node limits option you can
specify the minimum and maximum count of
nodes which cluster can be shrunk or
expanded to using Auto scale
in our demo we will retain the default
values of 3 and 4 respectively
finally click the submit button
congratulations the cluster has been
configured to Auto scale nodes in this
private cloud
to learn more about Auto scale policies
and configuring it in your private Cloud
environment check out this documentation
thanks for watching foreign